Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. our star spangles union jack flutters so proud over the dancing heads of the merry patriotic crowd yeah tip your hat to the yankee conquerors we've got no reds under the bed with guns under our pillows we're the 51st state of america yeah we're the 51st state of America. Well, so said the British rock band New Model Army back in 1986, capturing the sense, very memorable to those of us who lived through the 80s, that America was taking over the world and we were all turning into little Americans. Well, welcome to The Rest Is History with me, Dominic Sambrick,
感谢收听《历史的余烬》（The Rest Is History）。想要收听每周的独家加更节目、无广告广播、抢先体验系列节目，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。我们的星条旗联合杰克旗在欢快的爱国人群的舞动头颅上方骄傲地飘扬，是的，向洋基征服者脱帽致敬吧，我们没有床底下的红党，枕头底下也没有枪，我们是美国的第五十一个州，是的，我们是美国的第五十一个州。嗯，英国摇滚乐队“新模范军”（New Model Army）早在1986年就这样唱过，捕捉到了一种对于我们这些经历过80年代的人来说记忆犹新的感觉，即美国正在接管世界，而我们都将变成小美国人。欢迎收听《历史的余烬》，我是多米尼克·桑布里克（Dominic Sandbrook），
and my own little American, Tom Holland. Yeehaw! Hey, Dominic. american tom holland yeehaw hey dominic hello so tom are you um do you are you an americanophile or americanophobe would you say like everybody i'm both i love america i uh of course everyone everyone loves america america culture but there are times where i feel slightly resentful about how much i love it i guess that's a hard frame. I was about to say that's a very British thing, but of course the French, I mean the French are both, I always think the French are both
还有我自己的小美国人汤姆·霍兰（Tom Holland）。耶哈！嘿，多米尼克。美国汤姆·霍兰 耶哈 嘿 多米尼克 你好 那么 汤姆 你是一个亲美派还是厌美派，你会怎么说？像所有人一样，我两者都是，我热爱美国，我……当然，每个人都热爱美国，美国的文化，但有时我会对我自己有多么热爱它感到微微的不满，我想这是一个很难界定的框架。我正要说这非常英国，但当然法国人——我的意思是法国人既是……我总觉得法国人既是
the biggest Americanophiles and the biggest Americanophobes. So they're the people who go on about Anglo-Saxon culture and all this, but they're also the world's biggest McDonald's consumers. Yeah, I guess for the French, I mean in the word Anglo-Saxon, for the French, they bundle Britain in with America. They do, don't they? To a degree, in the word Anglo-Saxon, for the French, they bundle Britain in with America. They do, don't they? To a degree. So it's Anglo-Saxons.
最大的亲美派，也是最大的厌美派。所以他们是那些喋喋不休地谈论盎格鲁-撒克逊文化之类的人，但他们也是世界上麦当劳最大的消费者。是的，我想对法国人来说，在“盎格鲁-撒克逊”这个词里，法国人把英国和美国捆绑在了一起。确实如此，不是吗？在某种程度上，在“盎格鲁-撒克逊”这个词中，法国人把英国和美国捆绑在了一起。确实如此，不是吗？在某种程度上。所以这就是盎格鲁-撒克逊人。
Whereas for us, there's the kind of nagging sense that, you know, we began it and now they've taken over. It's a bit like us with sport. You know, we invent the sports and then everyone comes and beats us. And slight feeling like that, I think, with America. It's the slightly staid older brother with the much cooler younger brother, isn't it? I always think. Of course, not something you'll be familiar with, Tom.
然而对我们来说，有一种挥之不去的感觉，你知道，我们开创了这一切，现在他们接管了。这有点像我们在体育运动方面的经历。你知道，我们发明了体育运动，然后所有人来把我们打败。我想，对美国，我们也有点这种感觉。这就像是一个稍微死板的哥哥，有一个酷得多的弟弟，对吧？我一直这么觉得。当然，你不会对这种感觉感到陌生，汤姆。
Yes. Yeah, that is very much where I am. That's where I am too. Okay. So Americanization. Do you know where the word Americanisation comes from? I hope you don't because I want to tell you. I don't, Dominic, and I'm not interested, so let's move right on.
是的。是的，这正是我所处的境地。这也是我的境地。好吧。那么，美国化。你知道“美国化”这个词是怎么来的吗？我希望你不知道，因为我想告诉你。我不知道，多米尼克，而且我不感兴趣，所以我们直接继续吧。
Go on. You've obviously been saving it up, bless you. I have, I have. So there's a book published in 1902 called The Americanisation of the World by the British newspaper editor W.T. Stead. And he basically said the United States is going to replace the British Empire. And, you know, we're all going to end up speaking American and all that kind of thing. And of course, he was right, wasn't he?
说吧。你显然憋了很久了，真难为你。我是说真的。所以，1902年出版了一本书，书名叫《世界的美国化》（The Americanisation of the World），作者是英国报纸编辑W.T.斯特德（W. T. Stead）。他基本上说，美国将取代大英帝国。而且，你知道的，我们最后都会说美式英语，诸如此类。当然，他是对的，不是吗？
I mean, we have become Americanized. I mean, you and I are both of that generation that I think our parents would have looked at us and said, oh, you're using a lot of American slang. You know, you wear Americanized. I mean, you and I are both of that generation that I think our parents would have looked at us and said, oh, you're using a lot of American slang. You know, you wear American clothes, you watch American TV, too much American TV, all that kind of thing. And we have to some extent grown up as little Americans, or at least people in the shadow of America, haven't we? Yeah, because we grew up in the 80s when we were the kind of unsinkable aircraft carrier for for america and so we were s-trip one so um i think that um after you know after the after the second world war through the cold war american power military power economic power the cultural power was a kind of crucial in i mean it was it was both a part of of um of Americanization but it was also served to disguise
我的意思是，我们已经变得美国化了。我的意思是，你和我都是那种让我觉得我们的父母看着我们会说，哦，你在用很多美国俚语。你知道的，你穿着美国化的……我的意思是，你和我都是那一代人，我想我们的父母看着我们会说，哦，你在用很多美国俚语。你知道的，你穿美国服装，你看美国电视，看太多美国电视，诸如此类。在某种程度上，我们作为小美国人长大，或者至少是生活在美国阴影下的人，不是吗？是的，因为我们在80年代长大，当时我们是美国的某种不沉的航空母舰，所以我们是……因此，我认为，你知道的，在第二次世界大战之后，经过冷战，美国的权力——军事权力、经济权力、文化权力——至关重要，我的意思是，它既是美国化的一部分，同时也用来掩饰
the hardness of American power yeah if you were if you were kind of into jeans and coke and American music then you might be slightly less worried about the large number of American um planes you know sovereign territory on your own country or um the economic power that uh the dollar exercises all that kind of thing and i think that that's i mean that's that that's been a kind of a feature of the ambivalences towards america certainly since the since the second world war but actually i don't i'm just interested though the so the word americanization dates back to the beginning of the 20th century yeah it it's a word that is being applied to something that
美国权力的强硬面，是的，如果你喜欢牛仔裤、可口可乐和美国音乐，你可能就不会那么担心你自己的国家有大量美国飞机、所谓的主权领土，或者美元所施加的经济权力，诸如此类。我认为，这——我的意思是，这一直是人们对美国矛盾情感的一个特征，当然自第二次世界大战以来一直是这样，但实际上，我只是觉得有趣，所以“美国化”这个词可以追溯到20世纪初，是的，它是一个被应用于某种
existed before that presumably in the 19th century yeah so the take up so actually i think most of the traffic was one way pretty much one way for most of the 19th century so you know dickens goes to america um british music hall um goes to america it does come back a bit but but we are the we are the big the big daddy and they are the kind of recipients of our culture um but then i think there's a sense probably about around about you know 1900 or so that um it's starting to come back the other way that we are reading american books uh we are becoming familiar with cowboys and so on. Yeah, so Buffalo Bill. Buffalo Bill and his Wild West show coming round and huge success.
在此之前就存在的事物上的词，大概在19世纪，是的。所以这种吸收……实际上，我认为在整个19世纪，绝大多数的文化交流都是单向的，几乎是单向的。所以，你知道的，狄更斯去美国，英国音乐厅演出去美国，它确实有点回流，但我们是大佬，他们是我们文化的接受者；但随后，我认为大约在1900年左右，有一种感觉，即它开始向反方向回流，我们正在阅读美国书籍，我们开始熟悉牛仔等等。是的，比如水牛比尔。水牛比尔和他的狂野西部表演巡回演出并获得了巨大成功。
And also American heiresses coming over. Yeah, that's right. I know that because that's in Downton Abbey. So it must be true. And so here's a funny thing for you. In 1914, T.S. Eliot, who's from Missouri, is in Oxford and he spoke in a debate at the Oxford Union, 1914,
还有美国女继承人来到欧洲。是的，没准。我知道这个，因为《唐顿庄园》里有。所以这一定是真的。这里有一件有趣的事。1914年，来自密苏里的T.S.艾略特（T.S. Eliot）在牛津，他在牛津辩论社（Oxford Union）的一次辩论中发言，那是1914年，
so before the First World War, about the Americanisation of Oxford. And what was he saying? He said, he was speaking for it, you know, the motion was, you know, this house deplores the Americanisation of Oxford. T.S. Eliot was speaking for it, and he said, we see ourselves as cultural missionaries, taking the gospel of America out to the world. I mean, he said it in a teasing way. It's hard to imagine tsl it being that being that funny actually but um yeah
也就是第一次世界大战之前，关于牛津的美国化。他当时在说什么？他说，他是支持这一趋势的，你知道，动议是，“本院痛心牛津的美国化”。T.S.艾略特对此表示支持，他说：“我们视自己为文化传教士，将美国的福音带给世界。”我的意思是，他是用一种开玩笑的语气说的。其实很难想象T.S.艾略特会那么幽默，但是……是的。
hey guys whoa that's a brilliant tsl impersonation tom i i mean worth the the um the entrance price for the podcast alone just to hear you do your my my famous cheers april is the cruelest month way to go guys yeah okay but but what was he saying what was he thinking that oxford how was he thinking oxford had been americanized uh clothes music you know um expressions so pg woodhouse's early books have a lot of the mixture of kind of upper class slang and kind of american slang as well that's one of pg woodhouse's big things and then i think i think if i'm going to pick one moment that i think marks americanization it's 1927 it's the jazz singer because that's the first time the al jolson film that people actually large numbers of people
嘿，伙计们，哇，那是个精彩的T.S.艾略特模仿秀，汤姆。我的意思是，光是听到你模仿我的——我著名的“四月是最残忍的月份”，这播客的门票钱就值了，干得好，伙计们。是的，好吧。但是他在说什么？他认为牛津……他是如何认为牛津被美国化的？服装、音乐、你知道的，表达方式，所以P.G.沃德豪斯（P.G. Wodehouse）早期的书里有很多上流社会俚语和美国俚语的混合，那是P.G.沃德豪斯的一大特色。然后我认为，如果我要挑一个标志着美国化的时刻，那就是1927年的《爵士歌手》（The Jazz Singer），因为那是阿尔·乔尔森（Al Jolson）的电影第一次让大量的人——
millions of people are hearing american accents and it's from that point in the 20s and 30s that you have i mean you have people discussing this in parliament about the fact that english kids are using american slang that they are or they're modeling themselves on movie stars and um with the first british the first british film with sound was done by hitchcock i think and the way they marketed it they said you can hear English as it should be spoken so instead of um instead of listening to all this kind of American timeless marketing phrase yeah well that's why I choose a film based on the quality of the spoken English um so I think from the 20s onwards I mean it's no coincidence that comes in the aftermath of the first world war and I think from the 20s onwards, I mean, it's no coincidence that comes in the aftermath of the First World War.
数以百万计的人——听到美国口音，正是从20年代和30年代开始，你有……我的意思是，议会里有人讨论英国孩子在用美国俚语，他们正在……或者他们在模仿电影明星，而且……英国第一部有声电影是希区柯克拍的，我想，他们营销这部电影的方式是，他们说你可以听到“应该这样说的英语”，所以而不是……而不是听所有这些美国式的永恒营销短语。是的，这就是为什么我根据口语的质量来选择电影。所以我想从20年代开始……我的意思是，这并非巧合，它发生在第一次世界大战之后，我认为从20年代开始，
And I think from the 20s onwards, you have this persistent anxiety, specifically in Britain. I mean, there are different kinds of anxiety elsewhere, but I think we have a very particular anxiety that we have been infiltrated, I guess, by American-ness. And you have that now when the demand the arguments about the culture wars and so on that we're actually we've just imported unthinkingly these American ideas and we're arguing about them and they don't apply to us I think that's true um but I think that that it's interesting that you know in terms of the culture wars which I think is actually the way that America is being most influential on us at the moment. Yeah. I'd agree with that. What's interesting is that that again is a kind of flip from when we were
你可以看到这种挥之不去的焦虑，特别是在英国。我的意思是，其他地方也有不同种类的焦虑，但我认为我们有一种非常特殊的焦虑，即我们被“美国性”所渗透了。当你现在看到文化战争等方面的争论时，你会发现我们实际上只是不加思考地引进了这些美国的理念，我们在为之争论，而它们根本不适用于我们。我认为这是真的，但我认为有趣的是，你知道的，就文化战争而言，我认为这实际上是美国目前对我们影响最大的方面。是的，我同意这一点。有趣的是，这又是一种反转，回到我们
growing up, when really it was the right that was very pro American. Yeah. All the debate around, you know, again, going back to us air bases in Britain, Greenham common campaigners,
成长的时候，当时实际上是右翼非常亲美。是的。所有关于——你知道的，再次回到英国的美军基地、格林汉姆康芒（Greenham Common）抗议者、
um, CND, uh, America was seen as the enemy. Thatcher was disliked, not just for her own sake but because she was seen as reagan's mole yes yeah the the the the kind of the explosion of finance in uh in with the big bang and everything in london was seen as a process of americanization yeah so canary wolf you know it had the look of amer, skyscrapers and things like that. So the sense that Americanisation was a kind of right-wing project,
核裁军运动（CND），美国被视为敌人。撒切尔夫人不仅因为她自身的原因而不受欢迎，还因为她被视为里根的卧底。是的。伦敦“金融大爆炸”（Big Bang）及其他一切中金融的爆发，被视为美国化的一个过程。是的，所以金丝雀码头（Canary Wharf），你知道的，它看起来像美国的摩天大楼之类。所以，“美国化”是一种右翼计划的感觉，
I think that's now flipped because I think that the debates, the passions in Britain at the moment are massively coming from America. So now I think it's the left that's been Americanised. So we're talking about Anglo-Saxons. The sense that that is a problematic phrase. Yeah, the word problematic. Absolutely, but you're no longer supposed to use the word Anglo-Saxon to describe the period between the end of the Roman Empire in Britain and the Norman conquest,
我认为现在已经反转了，因为我认为英国目前的辩论和激情在很大程度上来自于美国。所以现在我认为是左翼被美国化了。因此我们正在谈论“盎格鲁-撒克逊”。这种感觉认为这是一个有问题的短语。是的，“有问题的”这个词。绝对的，但你不再被允许使用“盎格鲁-撒克逊”一词来描述英国罗马帝国结束到诺曼征服之间的时期，
because Anglo-Saxon is seen as being an inherently racist, white supremacist phrase. But that's only the case in America. Yeah. Yeah, I've seen that. You've been involved in that argument, haven't you? Well, it's infuriating. It's infuriating because, you know, they want, they say we should use, you know, early, early medieval England or early English, but it's the English Defence League. It's not the Anglo-Saxon Defence League. Anglo-Saxon doesn't have that connotations here in Britain. It's a purely American connotation, but because it's American academics leading it,
因为“盎格鲁-撒克逊”被视为一个本质上具有种族主义色彩、白人至上主义的词汇。但那仅限于美国。是的。是的，我见过这个。你曾经卷入过那场争论，不是吗？这太令人恼火了。这太令人恼火了，因为，你知道，他们希望……他们说我们应该使用，你知道的，早期中世纪英格兰或早期英语，但它是英国防卫联盟（English Defence League），而不是盎格鲁-撒克逊防卫联盟。在英国，盎格鲁-撒克逊并没有这种内涵。这纯粹是美国的内涵，但因为是美国学者在领导这场运动，
British academics, or some of them, kind of obediently say, oh, well, we must abolish this phrase. And ignoring the fact that, of course, as we've already discussed, Anglo-Saxon has a quite different connotation for the French or the Germans. So I think that that is
英国学者，或者其中的一些人，就顺从地说：“哦，好吧，我们必须废除这个词。”并且无视这样一个事实，即正如我们已经讨论过的，对于法国人或德国人来说，“盎格鲁-撒克逊”有着完全不同的内涵。所以我觉得，
that that's been the kind of the intriguing change is that now it's the left that's been Americanized I can actually get a kind of strain of suspicion in the on the on the right about America yeah I completely agree with you and I think that's because it's partly been driven by the internet hasn't it so that um if you're a sort of engaged liberal sort of academic intellectually kind of person then you're part of a sort of you see yourself as part of a conversation that's dominated by Americans simply because there are far more of them speaking your language than there are of you. teaching undergraduate courses about white supremacy in America and white supremacy being a very specific thing to do with slavery and the sort of incomplete legacy of reconstruction at the end of the Civil War and the creation of these kind of white supremacist regimes in the American South. And it was a very distinct, specific American thing. And now, now of course white supremacy is a is a sort of concept that is banded
这是一个耐人寻味的转变，现在是左翼被美国化了，而我实际上可以在右翼身上发现一种对美国的怀疑情绪。是的，我完全同意你的看法，我认为这是因为这部分是由互联网驱动的，不是吗？所以如果你是一个参与其中的自由派、某种类型的学者、知识分子，那么你就会把自己视为由美国人主导的对话的一部分，仅仅因为说你的语言的美国人比你们多得多。教授关于美国白人至上主义的本科课程，而白人至上主义是一件非常具体的事情，与奴隶制、内战结束后重建的不完整遗产，以及在美国南方建立这些白人至上主义政权有关。这是一件非常独特、具体的美国的事情。而现在，当然，白人至上主义是一个被
around in a very vague undefined way and people talk about white supremacy in britain and and european countries and so on and it's not the same thing at all what they've basically done is just taken an american term and that's true almost all these cultural battles the statue toppling started in america well i mean some of it started in south africa but a lot of the the most notable examples are confederate statues in america and people copy effectively been copying what they see in the states and translating it to the sort of british cultural landscape and i think that is a big change because that's not something that left liberal people would have done when we were growing up in the 70s and 80s is it i mean they would have recoiled from the idea of america so so the question is um is this it does
以非常模糊、未定义的方式到处乱用的概念，人们在英国和欧洲国家等地谈论白人至上主义，这根本不是同一回事。他们基本上所做的只是借用了一个美国术语，几乎所有的这些文化斗争都是如此——推倒雕像始于美国——好吧，我的意思是，其中一些始于南非，但许多最引人注目的例子是美国的邦联雕像，人们有效地复制了他们在美国看到的东西，并将其转化到英国的文化景观中。我认为这是一个巨大的变化，因为这并不是我们在70年代和80年代成长时期的左翼自由派会做的事，不是吗？我的意思是，他们会对美国的这种想法退避三舍。所以问题是，
it happen simply because um we speak the same language and so we are prone to think that that phrases that are banded about in america have a relevance here or does it go further than that is there a desire to kind of be american um so in a sense the the desire to to feel that you're fighting white supremacy or whatever here in the way that radicals are in in in america that presumably is kind of drawing it's part of a continuum that reaches back through people in the 60s being inspired by hippies or whatever, the example of music there, into the 50s through rock and roll. I guess ultimately, again, going back to the 30s and the 20s through Hollywood, that America just kind of provides the template for kind of, you know, what it is to be cool, to be cutting edge, to be on the zeitgeist. There is a bit of that. Actually, a great example, you mentioned the 60s,
这是否发生仅仅是因为我们说相同的语言，所以我们倾向于认为在美国流传的短语在这里也有关联？还是说这比这更深远，存在一种想要变得“美国化”的渴望？所以从某种意义上说，渴望在这里感觉自己正在与白人至上主义或其他什么作斗争，就像美国的激进分子所做的那样，这大概是一种延续，通过60年代受到嬉皮士或其他事物启发的人——音乐在那里的例子——一直延伸到50年代的摇滚乐。我想最终，同样，通过好莱坞追溯到30年代和20年代，美国只是为……什么是酷、什么是前沿、什么是时代精神，提供了一种模板。确实有这么一点。实际上，一个很好的例子，你提到了60年代，
is the British protests against the Vietnam War. I mean, we weren't in the Vietnam War. But people have protested about it anyway. Yes. So that's pure Americanisation. I mean, that really is just copycat, kind of. We've seen it, so let's do it in Grosvenor Square in 1968. Yeah, I think there's also a deeply buried sense, I think,
就是英国对越南战争的抗议。我的意思是，我们并没有卷入越南战争。但人们无论如何都在抗议。是的。所以这纯粹是美国化。我的意思是，这真的只是盲目效仿。我们看到了，所以让我们1968年在格罗夫纳广场（Grosvenor Square）也这么做。是的，我认为还有一种深埋的感觉，
that America is the kind of fulfilment of Britain. And that obviously goes back to the 18th century, when in the US War of Independence, that America was the kind of summation of the British kind of, you know, the liberal experience, I suppose, the good old cause of the English Civil War, that America was the realisation of that, and that we were moving, you know, we're sort of moving towards becoming America. But that's also there in France, isn't it? So you have, I'm kind of thinking, you know,
即美国是英国的一种“实现”。这显然可以追溯到18世纪，当时在美国独立战争中，美国被视为英国的某种总结，你知道的，自由主义经验，英国内战的伟大正义事业，美国是这一切的实现，而我们正在向前迈进，我们正朝着变成美国的方向发展。但这在法国也存在，不是吗？所以你有……我是在想，你知道的，
one of the very first, not exactly Americanisation looking to america as as an example there's a famous meeting in i think 1778 something like that where benjamin franklin is the ambassador to paris um of the of you know the newly founded american republic and meets voltaire and introduces his grandson to voltaire and voltaire kind of blesses him in English and basically says yeah America you're great yee-haw equivalent Yee-haw Voltaire with an American accent this is spiralling off
最早的……不能完全说是美国化，而是将美国视作一个榜样。有一个著名的会议，我想是在1778年左右，本杰明·弗兰克林（Benjamin Franklin）作为刚刚建立的美利坚共和国驻巴黎的大使，见到了伏尔泰（Voltaire），并将他的孙子介绍给伏尔泰，伏尔泰用英语祝福了他，基本上是说：“耶！美国，你们太棒了，耶哈的等同物。”带着美国口音的伏尔泰。这正朝着
in directions that I had not anticipated but there's a sense I mean kind of just at the right at the beginning that Voltaire is kind of handing over the torch of the enlightenment to Franklin who is you know the embodiment of a republic before France has become a republic or anything like that and and the sense that you know it's a new world and new worlds are good yes it's America being the future and I think that's actually it's a new world and new worlds are good yes it's america being the future and i think that's actually what's really interesting about the last few years is that that's the it's the first point that i can really think of when america has not felt like the future when um so so all
我没有预料到的方向发展，但有一种感觉——我的意思是，在最开始的时候，伏尔泰似乎将启蒙运动的火炬传递给了弗兰克林，而弗兰克林（在法国成为共和国之前）就是共和国的化身，而且有一种感觉，你知道的，这是一个新世界，新世界是美好的。是的，美国就是未来，而我认为这实际上……这是一个新世界，新世界是美好的。是的，美国就是未来，而我认为这实际上是过去几年里真正有趣的地方，这是我能真正想到的第一个时期，在这个时期，美国不再让人觉得是未来，当……
through the 20th century when people were arguing about america or when people said reagan is a you know nixon is a nazi reagan a fascist, all this sort of stuff, they still never doubted that America was ahead of Europe to some extent. I mean, America was literally ahead. They got their films earlier. They, you know, pioneered Coke and McDonald's and Levi's and rock and roll and all this sort of stuff. But I detect in the last sort of 10 years or so, especially with the Trump sort of imbroglio,
所以在整个20世纪，当人们争论美国时，或者当人们说“里根是……尼克松是纳粹，里根是法西斯”这类话时，他们从未怀疑过美国在某种程度上领先于欧洲。我的意思是，美国在字面上是领先的。他们更早看到电影。他们，你知道的，率先推出了可口可乐、麦当劳、李维斯（Levi's）、摇滚乐以及所有这些东西。但我察觉到，在过去大约10年里，特别是随着特朗普式的混乱，
a sense that America is no longer seen as humanity's future or the West's future, that America, you know, there's this real sense of having taken a wrong turn or taken a... And you can sense the yearning that people have, actually, in the West for america to represent an ideal by the fact that so many people you know who i'm sure we both know when biden was elected and when he was inaugurated and all that sort of stuff they sort of said oh isn't it great isn't it now they don't say that when there's the changing of the guard in belgium you know america has this
有一种感觉，即美国不再被视为人类的未来或西方的未来，美国……你知道，有一种真正的感觉，觉得它走错了路或者……你可以感觉到西方人对美国代表理想的渴望，通过这样一个事实：许多人——你知道的，我确信我们都认识——当拜登当选、当他宣誓就职以及所有这些事情发生时，他们会说：“哦，这不是很棒吗？这难道不是……”现在，当比利时政权更迭时，他们可不说这话。你知道，美国有着这种
special place but isn't there also a kind of paradox that um that that although america is no longer a kind of moral exemplar it it is a kind of an it's become an exemplar of um of evil um so if you were the victim of uh you know an oppressive state apparatus do it be one in america because then your name will appear on placards, on posters. You know, in Europe, people will campaign and march and give speeches about George Floyd. But you look at what's happening in China, where... And you're going to say that, you're absolutely right. Yeah, but it's, I mean, it's not a kind of not not dealing with the kind of the moral issues of whether an American life matters more than, you know, someone in a Uyghur life. But it's it's although China is now, you know, we've talked about this, that China is kind of coming up.
特殊的地位。但这难道不是也有一种悖论吗？——尽管美国不再是一种道德楷模，但它却成为了一种……它已经成为了一种“邪恶”的楷模。所以，如果你是一个……压迫性国家机器的受害者，那就成为美国的一个受害者吧，因为这样你的名字就会出现在标语牌上、海报上。你知道，在欧洲，人们会为乔治·弗洛伊德（George Floyd）发起运动、游行并发表讲话。但你看看中国正在发生的事情，那里……你正要这么说，你完全说对了。是的，但这……我的意思是，这并不是一种……不去处理这样一个道德问题——即一条美国人的生命是否比一个维吾尔人的生命更重要。但这是……尽管中国现在是……我们已经讨论过这个，中国正在崛起。
It feels like it's you know, it's now a bipolar world. world in a sense it isn't as long as the death of an american matters more in the streets of of europe than you know the incarceration of an entire people yeah because i think that that it's it's an expression of the whole that america has and you know again going back to kind of the idea of white supremacy and all that kind of stuff it in a sense saying that this is uniquely evil, it's uniquely terrible, is a manifestation of Americanization. It's kind of saying America matters more, it matters more what happens in America than what happens in China or whatever. I'd agree with that. And I think there's also a sense, both for Americans and for people writing or talking about America, that America is always the center, the story is always about America. Soica so you know there's a coup somewhere in latin america or or there's um you know there's a
感觉它现在是一个两极世界。从某种意义上说，只要一个美国人的死在欧洲街头的重要性超过……你知道的，一个全体人民被监禁（的重要性）……是的，因为我认为这是美国所拥有的一种权力的表现，而且你知道，再次回到白人至上主义之类的概念，从某种意义上说，声称这是独一无二的邪恶，是独一无二的可怕，这就是美国化的表现。这有点像在说美国更重要，在美国发生的事情比在中国或其他地方发生的事情更重要。我同意这一点。我认为还有一种感觉，无论是对于美国人还是对于撰写或谈论美国的人来说，美国永远是中心，故事总是关于美国的。
revolution somewhere in in east asia and it you know you know you can bet your bottom dollar there'll be people marching against the u.s government's role in it and writing books to say it was all plotted by the cia and all that thing. America is always the centre and the centre of the story and America is always held to different expected, it's held to different standards. Don't you think it's held to... Yeah, I do. But again, just kind of moving on from that and slightly
所以，你知道，拉丁美洲某地发生了一场政变，或者东亚某地发生了一场革命，你可以押上全部身家，肯定会有人游行抗议美国政府在其中的角色，并写书说这一切都是由中央情报局（CIA）策划的，诸如此类。美国永远是中心，是故事的中心，美国总是受到不同的期待，它受到不同的标准约束。你不觉得它受到……是的，我确实这么认为。不过，再次回到这一点，稍微
twist the argument. So we've been talking about the relationship of Britain particularly and the Anglophone world and perhaps those parts of Europe that speak English very fluently, so the Netherlands andlands and scandinavia whatever um in france there's a the whole kind of you know the low work is the guy there's really it's that that that's kind of you know there's a there's a major national debate going on about whether um american what they see as kind of alien ideological approaches are suitable to france but i would say
扭转一下辩论方向。所以我们一直在讨论英国与英语世界的关系，以及欧洲那些英语说得很流利的地区，比如荷兰和斯堪的纳维亚半岛什么的。在法国，整个……你知道，洛克（Lowork）是个家伙，真的，那里正在发生一场重大的国家辩论，关于美国人——他们视为异质的意识形态方法——是否适合法国。但我会说，
further going beyond the bounds of europe and what we might traditionally describe as the west i think that actually america is no longer the center so i think in the middle east where you know it's been blundering in and starting wars all over the place actually america is now just one actor among many you know in you know in lots of ways china and russia are just as significant players and i think that in in um you know in asia where there's the feeling that you know america is kind of on retreat it doesn't matter and i do think that they're you know all the stuff you know the past year it's it's it's irrelevant to them. But not culturally, though, Tom, right? So to start getting into some questions,
进一步超越欧洲的边界以及我们传统上可能描述为西方的范围，我认为实际上美国不再是中心了。所以我想在中东，你知道的，它一直在那里笨手笨脚地挑起各地的战争，实际上美国现在只是众多参与者之一，你知道，在很多方面，中国和俄罗斯同样是重要的参与者。我认为在……你知道的，在亚洲，有一种感觉，即美国正在撤退，它并不重要，而且我确实认为，你知道的，过去一年的所有事情，对他们来说都是无关紧要的。但并非在文化上，对吧，汤姆？所以，开始探讨一些问题，
Jacob Hawkins says, was Americanization possible because English was already the lingua franca? Which is actually a really good question. And then he says, and will a language barrier prevent Sinozation or whatever the Chinese equivalent of Americanization is? So let's pick up your point. Clearly, Chinese money and Chinese kind of political clout matters in Africa and in Eurasia
雅各布·霍金斯（Jacob Hawkins）问：“美国化之所以可能，是因为英语已经是通用语吗？”这其实是一个非常好的问题。然后他说：“语言障碍会阻碍‘中国化’或任何相当于美国化概念的东西吗？”所以让我们来谈谈你的观点。显然，中国资金和中国政治影响力在非洲和欧亚大陆的重要性
in a way that it never did before, and that is arguably eclipsing America. There's no doubt about that. But nobody looks to Chinese moral examples or to Chinese cultural examples, do they? I mean, nobody swoons before Chinese pop stars or Chinese films or, or indeed, you know, even Chinese kind of cultural habits and stuff. It's still America, partly because of English, because the British Empire had kind of done a lot of the heavy lifting for it and turning English into the language of business and commerce and stuff. Don't you think that America still plays that part because of the language in a way that China perhaps never will? Yeah, maybe. I mean, I think that if you speak a language, of course, you then see the world through a particular prism. And,
是以往从未有过的，可以说正在使美国黯然失色。这是毫无疑问的。但是没有人把中国当作道德榜样或文化榜样，对吧？我的意思是，没有人对中国流行歌星或中国电影神魂颠倒，或者甚至对……你知道，甚至是中国的某种文化习惯之类的事情神魂颠倒。依然是美国，部分是因为英语，因为大英帝国在将英语变成商业和贸易等语言方面做了大量繁重的工作。你不认为美国仍然因为语言而扮演着这个角色，而中国或许永远不会吗？
you know, the very words that you use kind of determine how you understand the world. And I agree that, of course, if you speak a language, then you're going to be more open to that country's films and music and so on. But having said that, I think that my sense is that ideologically and culturally, America matters less in Asia now than it did 10, certainly 20 years ago. And I wonder whether that weathering process is going to accelerate over the next decades. I would guess that it probably would. And I would imagine that certainly in areas that it's important to speak to the Chinese, inevitably people are going to start learning Chinese because language is an index of cultural and economic
是的，也许吧。我的意思是，如果你说一种语言，你当然就会通过特定的棱镜来看待世界。而且，
and often military power. That's why they spread. That's why the British Empire managed to spread English around the world. And it's why America spread English around the world. And we may, I suppose you're right, that we're only at the beginning of that process, aren't we? So although nobody speaks Chinese now, other than Chinese people, and nobody watches Chinese TV or anything like that,
你所使用的词汇决定了你如何理解世界。我同意，当然，如果你说一种语言，你就会更乐于接受那个国家的电影、音乐等等。但话虽如此，我的直觉是，在意识形态和文化上，美国在亚洲的重要性现在已经不如10年前，甚至20年前了。我不知道这种风化过程在未来几十年是否会加速。我猜它可能会。而且我想，当然，在需要与中国人对话的领域，人们不可避免地会开始学习中国话，因为语言是文化、经济
maybe in 50 years' time it might be a different story. Well, I've certainly started watching more Chinese films over the past two decades. I don't think I've ever seen a Chinese film. I know that's very shaming. Well, I love all the brilliant Chinese films where they all jump through bamboo shoots and fight each other. It's, it's all great stuff. I'm aware that I'm not... Is that a Crouching Tiger, Hidden Dragon? Is that a Chinese film?
以及通常是军事力量的指标。这就是它们传播的原因。这就是大英帝国设法将英语传播到世界各地的原因，也是美国将英语传播到世界各地的原因。我想你是对的，我们可能才刚刚开始这个过程，不是吗？所以尽管现在除了中国本土之外没有人说汉语，也没有人看中国电视或类似的东西，
Yes, and there's a wonderful film that we mentioned... So I have seen one. Yeah, and there's a wonderful film that we mentioned in the podcast with Michael Wood called Hero, which is all about the first emperor and the unifying of China, which is the most arrant state propaganda imaginable. I mean, it's basically saying it's brilliant,
也许在50年后的未来，情况可能会有所不同。嗯，在过去的二十年里，我确实开始观看更多中国电影了。我想我从来没看过中国电影。我知道这很丢脸。嗯，我喜欢所有那些精彩的中国电影，里面的人都在竹林里跳来跳去、互相打斗。这……这都是很棒的内容。我知道我没有……那是《卧虎藏龙》（Crouching Tiger, Hidden Dragon）吗？那是中国电影吗？
millions of people die, but it's all for the cause of China but i said i assumed i assumed you were just sucking up to michael wood i didn't i didn't think you'd actually i really had um uh should we have a break at this point i think we should commercial break yeah right to hear from our sponsors while we enjoy some candy and coke i'm marina hyde and i'm richard osmond and together we host the rest is entertainment it's your weekly fix of entertainment news reviews splash of showbiz gossip and on our q a we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works we have just launched our members club if you want ad-free listening bonus episodes and early
是的，还有我们在播客中提到的那部由迈克尔·伍德（Michael Wood）出演的精彩电影《英雄》（Hero），讲的全是始皇帝和中国统一的故事，这是可以想象到的最公然的国家宣传。我的意思是，它基本上是在说太棒了，
access to live tickets head to the rest of the entertainment.com that's the rest is entertainment.com welcome back to the rest is history with me and my partner um tom holland my partner i was sort of thinking cowboy but not in the brokebackback Mountain sense of cowboys. Very, very much not, listeners. Okay, Tom, let's do some questions. Let's get into some questions. I'm going to kick off with, I'm just going to do them in order. So the first two, the producers written read together, which I will. Anthony Sanders says, how much of Americanization has been the accident of Hollywood and Silicon Valley both being from there?
数百万人死了，但这一切都是为了中国的伟业……但我以为……我以为你只是在拍迈克尔·伍德的马屁，我没想到你真的……我真的……我们是不是该在这时休息一下？我想我们应该这么做。商业广告时间。好的，在我们享用一些糖果和可口可乐的同时，来听听我们赞助商的话。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde），我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman），我们共同主持《娱乐的余烬》（The Rest is Entertainment）。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论、一丝八卦绯闻的固定节目，在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐业的神秘面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部，如果你想要无广告收听、加更节目以及抢先购买现场门票，请访问 therestisentertainment.com，那是 therestisentertainment.com。欢迎回到我和我的搭档——汤姆·霍兰一起主持的《历史的余烬》。我的搭档——我本来在想牛仔，但不是《断背山》（Brokeback Mountain）那种意义上的牛仔。绝不是，绝不是，听众们。好吧，汤姆，让我们来回答一些问题。让我们进入问答环节。我将从头开始，就按顺序来。所以前两个，制作人写在一起，我也会一起读。安东尼·桑德斯（Anthony Sanders）问：“美国化在多大程度上是好莱坞和硅谷恰好都发源于那里的巧合？
And how much is it because of their sort of hegemony? So is it just coincidence? Americanization has been the accident of Hollywood and Silicon Valley both being from there and how much is it because of their sort of hegemony so is it just coincidence and Margaret Eyde said says another Americanization question um to what extent is the great Americanization in Britain compared to elsewhere in Western Europe and is this because of the accident of language so I guess two kind of accident questions so Tom well I think saying Americanization is simply an accident of Hollywood and Silicon Valley um I mean both of them are expressions of American power yeah you need the money you need the infrastructure you need the intellectual capital that enables you to set these incredible, massive, century-defining industries on two legs. And then, of course, it's a virtuous circle because if you are sending out your films, if you're sending out software and hardware or whatever for computing, then you're embedding your cultural power, aren't you?
又有多少是因为它们的某种霸权呢？所以这只是巧合吗？”玛吉·艾德（Margaret Eyde）问了另一个关于美国化的问题：“英国与西欧其他地方相比，其受美国化的程度有多大？这是否是因为语言的巧合？”所以这是两个关于巧合的问题。汤姆，嗯，我认为把美国化简单地归结为好莱坞和硅谷的巧合……我的意思是，这两者都是美国力量的表现。是的，你需要资金，你需要基础设施，你需要知识产权资本，这些使你能够将这些不可思议的、庞大的、定义了世纪的产业建立起来。然后，当然，这是一个良性循环，因为如果你在输出电影，如果你在输出计算机的软件和硬件之类的东西，那么你就在巩固你的文化力量，不是吗？
Yeah, I think that's true i mean i think there's probably a tiny element of contingency with hollywood in that hollywood was very fortunate because of the first world war so the first war basically ripped out its competitors so the french film industry particularly um the french film production collapsed basically in the first world war and afterwards in the 20s when there was an appetite for cinema in the 20s and 30s and 40s already the hey World War. And afterwards in the 20s, when there was an appetite for cinema, in the 20s and 30s and 40s, already the heyday of cinema, it was American films that filled the gap.
是的，我认为这是真的。我的意思是，好莱坞可能带有一点点偶然性，因为好莱坞非常幸运，第一次世界大战基本上摧毁了它的竞争对手。所以法国电影产业，尤其是法国电影制作，在第一次世界大战中基本上崩溃了。而在那之后，在20年代，当人们对电影产生胃口时，在20年代、30年代和40年代——已经处于电影的黄金时期——是美国电影填补了空白。
So, you know, had it not been for the First World War, Hollywood would have faced more competition. But I think you're probably right. It's the biggest domestic market, isn't it? And the most dynamic market in the 20th century. So of course it was going to create Hollywood. And of course Silicon Valley was going to happen in America, simply because the demand, the potential consumer base, is so much greater than anywhere else.
所以，要不是因为第一次世界大战，好莱坞将面临更多的竞争。但我想你可能是对的。这是最大的国内市场，不是吗？也是20世纪最具活力的市场。所以它当然会催生好莱坞。而且硅谷也注定会在美国发生，仅仅是因为需求、潜在的消费者基础比其他任何地方都要大得多。
And the military. Yeah, of course, the military. The contribution of the military to the internet and everything. Again, you need, so that's a kind of crucial aspect of it as well. Yeah, it couldn't have worked out any other way. You wouldn't have had Silicon Valley in the Netherlandsetherlands i mean that was never going to happen well i'd say that that brings us to the the issue of language uh and i'd be interested to i mean maybe if we've got dutch or scandinavian listeners who you know whose english is better than us
还有军方。是的，当然，军方。军方对互联网和一切的贡献。再次说明，你需要它，所以这也是其中的一个关键方面。是的，不可能有其他的发展方式。你不可能在荷兰建立硅谷，我的意思是那绝对不可能发生。嗯，我想这把我们带到了语言的问题上，我也很有兴趣……我的意思是，也许如果我们有荷兰或斯堪的纳维亚听众，他们的英语比我们还要好，
basically um you know do you do you feel that uh your facility with english means that you are more exposed to american influence than but here's a big difference tom an interesting difference is that um different school systems teach different kinds of english so okay you're um so my wife once had a norwegian house housemate when they were students who speaks very upper class English. Because in Norway, that's the form. But in some countries, they speak with an American accent. Which countries? Villainous countries.
基本上……你知道，你是否觉得你对英语的熟练掌握意味着你比其他人更容易受到美国的影响？但这里有一个很大的区别，汤姆，一个有趣的区别是：不同的学校系统教授不同种类的英语。所以，好吧，你是……所以我的妻子在他们还是学生时曾有一个挪威室友，那个人说的是非常上流社会的英语。因为在挪威，那是标准。但在某些国家，他们说话带有美国口音。哪些国家？罪恶的国家吗？
Villainous? I don't know. Maybe the Dutch? Do the Dutch speak English, Americanised English? I always thought the Dutch spoke with a Dutch accent. i don't know maybe the dutch to the dutch speak english i americanized english the dutch accent well they can't lose the dutch yeah they can't lose the dutchness that's for sure but just to turn this on the head i mean i suppose the one positive for us is that um it does also make it easy for us to then invade america so in the 60s you know in the 50s yeah popular music invades britain um and in 60s the beatles and so on invade america and that's purely because of the language right because they
罪恶的？我不知道。也许是荷兰人？荷兰人说英语吗？带有美国化的英语？我一直以为荷兰人说英语时带有荷兰口音。我不知道，也许荷兰人……荷兰人说英语吗？带有美国化的英语？荷兰口音——好吧，他们改不掉荷兰腔，那是肯定的。但反过来看，我的意思是，我想对我们来说的一个积极方面是，这也让我们更容易去“侵犯”美国。所以在60年代，你知道的，在50年代，流行音乐侵入英国，而在60年代披头士乐队等侵入美国，这纯粹是因为语言，对吧？因为他们
can go over to america they're singing in america but they can do interviews they can and and the the englishness gives them a calling card that no american band can match so it gives them an exoticism and it makes them different. So all the things that we think of, I mean, American bands, when they come here, they have the American-ness, which is a calling card. But our band's very British-ness. If they play it right, it's quirky, it's funny, and if they press those buttons,
可以去美国，他们在那里唱歌，但他们可以做采访，而且……这种英国特质给了他们一张任何美国乐队都无法企及的名片，这赋予了他们一种异国情调，让他们与众不同。所以我们所认为的所有这一切——我的意思是，美国乐队来到这里时，他们身上带有“美国性”，这是一张名片。但我们乐队的“英国性”，如果他们运用得当，它是古怪的、有趣的，如果他们按对了这个按钮，
they can enjoy success that a similar American band couldn't. Or a French band. Yeah, it couldn't. Or a French band. Yeah, it would be impossible for a French band because they'd open their mouths to talk and people would start laughing at them. But even Daft Punk have to, you know, it's all in English. Yeah. Which merely confirming French suspicions of the Anglo-Saxons
他们就能获得一个同类美国乐队无法获得的成功。或者法国乐队。是的，不可能。或者法国乐队。是的，对于法国乐队来说是不可能的，因为他们一张嘴说话，人们就会开始嘲笑他们。但即使是蠢朋克（Daft Punk）也必须……你知道，这全都是用英语唱的。是的，这仅仅证实了法国人对盎格鲁-撒克逊人的怀疑。
rather than specifically Americans. And perhaps it's telling that the first big, the first European band to really go global, I suppose, is ABBA. And they spoke very good English from a country where people did speak excellent English. Okay, Dominic, our next question is from Jack Davenport, who in fact is our producer. So cheers, Jack. Thanks for this.
而不是特指美国人。也许很有说明意义的是，我认为，第一支真正走向全球的大型欧洲乐队是 ABBA。他们英语说得非常好，而且他们来自一个人们英语说得很棒的国家。好了，多米尼克，我们的下一个问题来自杰克·达文波特，他实际上是我们的制作人。所以，干杯，杰克。谢谢你的提问。
How Americanised has the world really been when only american teams take part in the world series it's a great question jack loves his sport yeah um so that's a good question isn't it because american sport nobody's interested in american sport are they no it's unless you're american it's a really strange thing isn't it that america has been so good at exporting everything else it's food it's taste it's a really strange thing isn't it that america has been so good at exporting everything else it's food it's taste it's cultural habits it's clothing but sport is the one thing that is it's basically completely failed i mean how many people in england which is probably the most pro-american country you know of all western european countries how many people know can name all the nfl teams or
当只有美国球队参加世界大赛时，世界究竟被美国化到了什么程度？这是一个很好的问题，杰克很热爱体育。是的，嗯，所以这是一个很好的问题，对吧？因为美国体育，没有人对美国体育感兴趣，对吧？不，除非你是美国人。这是一个非常奇怪的现象，对吧？美国在出口其他东西方面做得如此之好——食物、品味、文化习俗、服装——但体育是唯一一个基本上彻底失败的领域。我是说，在英国——这可能是所有西欧国家中最亲美的国家——有多少人能说出所有NFL球队的名字，或者
even know who was in the super bowl or certainly baseball i mean who cares about baseball um and that's a really strange i guess their domestic market is big enough that they almost don't need to worry about tailoring it for an international audience but also i guess it's in international sport was created by the brit Empire, wasn't it? I mean, football was exported, cricket, obviously, rugby, and America maybe entered too late. Would you buy that? When American power became big enough to export their sport, the British sports were already too well established.
甚至知道谁进了超级碗，或者棒球——我是说，谁在乎棒球啊？嗯，这真的是一件很奇怪的事。我猜他们的国内市场足够大，以至于他们几乎不需要考虑为国际受众量身定制。但我也觉得，国际体育是由大英帝国创立的，对吧？我是说，足球是被出口的，板球显然也是，橄榄球也是，而美国可能切入得太晚了。你认同这个观点吗？当美国的力量变得足够强大以至于可以出口他们的体育时，英国的体育项目已经根深蒂固了。
But you could say with football, and I know we're going to have Jonathan Wilson on in a couple of weeks to do an entire episode on the history of football but but you could say that um british power and influence in the 19th century early 20th century you know spread it around the world and then britain's relative decline meant that it wasn't it was no longer identified as a british sport so it could become a global sport yeah whereas whereas everything american is kind of american you know in america it's american we call it american football um baseball is a kind of icon of america and perhaps um you know perhaps it's just too culturally tied in with america i don't know i
但你可以说，关于足球——我知道我们几周后会请乔纳森·威尔逊来做一个关于足球历史的完整单集——但你可以说，嗯，英国在19世纪和20世纪初的力量和影响力，你知道的，将其传播到了世界各地，然后英国相对地位的衰落意味着它不再被视为一项英国运动，因此它能够成为一项全球性运动。是的，然而，与之形成对比的是，一切带美国色彩的东西都是那种“美国式”的——你知道，在美国，它就是美国的，我们管它叫美式足球；棒球是美国的一种标志，也许，你知道的，也许它只是在文化上与美国绑得太紧了，我不知道，我
don't know i think that's a really good point actually i mean that's one way that britain so um british popular culture started to be exported at the point at which the british empire lost its potency. So in other words, you could embrace, you could listen to the Beatles without, you know, betraying yourself as irredeemably pro-British and being slagged off by your contemporaries, your nationalistic contemporaries or something. But American sport, you're right. If you're, you know, in, I don't know,gypt or something and you're a great nfl fan and you're
我不知道，我觉得这其实是一个很好的观点。我是说，这是英国的一种方式，所以——英国流行文化开始被出口，正是在大英帝国失去潜力的那个时间点。换句话说，你可以去拥抱、去听披头士乐队，而不需要，你知道的，出卖自己，让自己变成无可救药的亲英分子，并遭到同代人、也就是你的民族主义同代人等的痛骂。但是美国的体育，你是对的。如果你，你知道的，在，我不知道，埃及什么的，而你是一个狂热的NFL球迷，并且你
you're devoted to the cleveland browns i mean that that carries so much cultural baggage doesn't it that it would be yeah you know politically it's a sort of it's a brave decision and it did you know it did in the after after the war you know teams would turn up to wembley and beat england and that would be a kind of rite of passage. And then England would cease to register. You know, England was just another football-playing country. It had no great significance at all. Whereas America, it will always be, I guess.
死心塌地支持克利夫兰布朗队，我的意思是，这承载了太多的文化包袱，对吧？以至于它会——是的，你知道的，在政治上，这是一种勇敢的决定。而且它确实，你知道的，在战后，你知道的，各支球队会来到温布利球场并击败英格兰，那将是一种通过仪式。然后英格兰就会不再引人注目。你知道的，英格兰只是又一个踢足球的国家。它根本没有多大意义。而美国，我猜它永远都会是。
And I guess because football, what we call football, is so popular, perhaps there just isn't room for a'm going to tell you a sporting ecosystem a sporting story a sporting anecdote so i was in the 1998 world cup in france in i think montpellier in a square and they put up a big screen and they showed all the games there and all the fans watched you know mingled it was this sort of fifa's dream of people all drinking beer and mingling happily and being friends wearing benetton yeah so we'd fallen in with a group of colombians at one point i remember and we were in this crowd maybe i don't know 2 000 people 3 000 people or something and the match was iran versus the united
而且我猜因为足球——我们称之为足球的那项运动——如此受欢迎，也许根本没有空间容纳……我来给你讲一个体育生态系统的故事，一个体育故事，一个体育轶事。所以我在1998年法国世界杯期间，我想是在蒙彼利埃的一个广场上，他们竖起了一个大屏幕，他们在那里播放了所有的比赛，所有的球迷都在观赛，你知道的，人群交融在一起。这就是国际足联的梦想——人们都在喝着啤酒，愉快地交融在一起，成为朋友，穿着贝纳通的衣服。是的。所以我们当时和一群哥伦比亚人混在了一起，我记得，我们在人群中，可能，我不知道，有2000人、3000人左右，比赛是伊朗对阵美国。
states this long-awaited showdown the iranians all gave flowers to the they did the iranians turned up with flowers right and there were two men next to us. They were basically Bill Bryson and Steven Spielberg. They were American soccer friends who traveled with their fanny packs, and they were there all prepared, and they were like soccer devotees, and this was their...
这场备受期待的对决。伊朗人全都给——他们这样做了，伊朗人带着花走上场，对吧？我们旁边有两个男人。他们基本上就是比尔·布莱森和斯蒂芬·斯皮尔伯格。他们是美国足球迷，背着腰包到处旅行，他们做好了充分的准备，就像是狂热的足球信徒，这就是他们的……
And it was awful because everybody in the square supported Iran very passionately. And as the Iranian goals went in, these two Americans looked more and more disconsolate. And it wasn't the fact their team were losing, it was just they realised how much the rest of the world desperately wanted Iran to win.
而且这太糟糕了，因为广场上的每个人都非常热情地支持伊朗。随着伊朗队的进球，这两个美国人看起来越来越沮丧。这并不是因为他们的球队在输球，而是因为他们意识到世界其他地方多么渴望伊朗队获胜。
But that's, we have the same. I mean, everybody wants England to lose. Do they? I'd never believe that. I don't believe that. In rugby they do, I think. Do they? Yeah, I suppose they do. In cricket, do they? I mean, they? Yeah, I suppose they do. They always want England to lose. Do they?
但那是——我们也有同样的情况。我是说，所有人都希望英格兰输。是吗？我绝不相信这一点。我不相信。在橄榄球里他们确实希望如此，我想。是吗？是的，我想他们确实这样。在板球里，他们也这样吗？我是说，他们？是的，我想他们确实这样。他们总是希望英格兰输。是吗？
I mean, are England the big baddies in cricket? No, not anymore. Sadly, that's because we're not good enough. And I don't even think that's true of football. I think everyone in Scotland wants England to lose. But I don't think people in Europe say, oh, anyone but England. I mean, I think they just think we're slightly a comic turn
我是说，英格兰是板球界的超级大反派吗？不，不再是了。可悲的是，那是因为我们不够优秀。而且我甚至不认为足球是这样的。我认为苏格兰的每个人都希望英格兰输。但我并不认为欧洲人会说，哦，谁都行，只要不是英格兰。我是说，我觉得他们只是认为我们稍微有点像个喜剧演员，
that crash out in the quarterfinals every year. Yeah, so we've lost our notoriety. I mean, imagine if America won the World Cup. Imagine if that happened. That would be awful, wouldn't it? It would be awful. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Okay, here's a question from James.
每年都在四分之一决赛中惨遭淘汰。是的，所以我们失去了恶名。我是说，想象一下如果美国赢得世界杯。想象一下如果发生了那种事。那会很糟糕，对吧？那会很糟糕。对，对，对。好了，这里有一个来自詹姆斯的提问。
It's an excellent one. Hi guys, love the pod. Say we like that. To what extent is Americanisation and American exceptionalism influenced by the widespread belief within the US.s that it's a nation blessed by god it's a gift to you this question dominic uh what's your view on that i think i can answer this with no need for any um input from you no i think this absolutely um so american exceptionalism is clearly
这是一个极好的问题。大家好，喜欢这个播客。我们喜欢听这个。美国化和美国例外论，在多大程度上受到了美国国内广泛存在的“美国是一个受上帝祝福的国家”这一信念的影响？这是送给你的问题，多米尼克，你对此有什么看法？我想我可以回答这个问题，完全不需要你的任何输入。不，我认为绝对有——所以，美国例外论显然
a very religiously infused idea the idea of the shining city on the hill. And that's an idea that they've got from 17th century English Puritanism, obviously. But I think Americans, irrespective of their religious identity, share that sense, don't they? They share the sense that America is a nation chosen by God, even if they don don't believe in god they think they're a chosen people um and that their nation is special it represents an ideal rather than just a sort of a story of shared belonging um and that it represents i mean even people who are the most sort of radical critics of the american government within america will often then go on to say because our country should mean something more than that because we've failed to live up to our ideals this isn't the real America right this isn't America this is what everybody said after that Trump riots wasn't it this is not America this is not who we are and everybody else outside America saying no no this is who you are we've seen the films
是一个带有浓厚宗教色彩的概念。山巅之城的理念。显然，这是他们从17世纪的英国清教主义中得到的理念。但我认为美国人，无论他们的宗教身份如何，都有这种共同的意识，对吧？他们有一种共同的意识，即美国是一个被上帝选中的国家，即使他们不信仰上帝，他们也认为自己是选民，并且他们的国家是特殊的；它代表了一种理想，而不仅仅是一种共同归属的故事。并且它代表了——我是说，甚至连美国国内对美国政府最激进的批评者，也经常会接着说：“因为我们的国家应该有比这更深刻的意义，因为我们未能达到我们的理想，这不是真正的美国，对吧？这不是美国，这不是我们真正的样子。”而美国以外的所有其他人都说：“不，不，这就是你们的样子，我们看过电影，
we've done the game the video games we know we know this but absolutely and i think it is completely religious this in inspiration this idea don't you yeah and i but i think that from our point of view i think that it's part of a common stock of kind of anglo-american protestantism uh and again i think that that means that it's not just one of the reasons that we're so kind of susceptible to it, open to it, ready to accept the justice of it, is because we share a common kind of seedbed of theological assumptions. So the idea that people should be awakened, that people are steeped in sin, that the spirit should descend and that people should be awakened, that people are steeped in sin, that the spirit should descend, and that people should be awakened. And you have this thing, the Great Awakening, that begins in Britain and spreads to America in the 18th century. And then you have a succession of them, because of course, you have an awakening, people are born again, they have their eyes
我们玩过游戏，电子游戏，我们知道，我们太知道了。”但绝对是的，而且我认为它的灵感完全来自于宗教，这个概念，你不觉得吗？对。而且我认为，从我们的角度来看，我认为这是盎格鲁-盎格鲁-萨克逊新教共同传统的一部分。再次我认为，这意味着它不仅是——我们之所以如此容易受其影响、对其实质开放、准备接受其正义性的原因之一，是因为我们共享了一套共同的神学假设土壤。所以，人们应该被唤醒、人们深陷罪恶之中、圣灵应该降临，以及人们应该被唤醒、人们深陷罪恶之中、圣灵应该降临，以及人们应该被唤醒的观念。你经历了这个事件：大觉醒运动，它始于英国并在18世纪传播到美国。然后你经历了一连串的觉醒，因为当然，你经历了一次觉醒，人们获得重生，他们双眼
opened, the spirit descends on them them and then they return back into sin. And, you know, it's a kind of truism to talk about the great awakening. But I think that it's it's manifestly in that tradition. And I think that that's why it's it's had the impact that it's had here is because we also are heirs to that kind of essentially protestant yeah sense that we're lost in sin and we need to be awakened to our moral responsibilities and the kind of and also the biblical narrative of exodus of a people in slavery who are chosen by god to be redeemed from the evil oppressor the imperialist oppressor um is is you know this is in its overtly biblical form is something that
睁开，圣灵降临到他们身上，然后他们又回到了罪恶之中。而且，你知道的，谈论大觉醒运动简直就像是一个老生常谈。但我认为它显然属于那个传统。我认为这就是为什么它在这里产生了它所产生的影响的原因，因为我们也是这种本质上属于新教的传统的继承者，这种新教意识让我们觉得自己迷失在罪恶中，我们需要被唤醒以承担道德责任，并且还有——还有出埃及记的圣经叙事：一群处于奴隶地位的人被上帝选中，从邪恶的压迫者、帝国主义压迫者手中被救赎——你知道的，这在其公开的圣经形式中是某种
martin luther king absolutely enshrined as the kind of the heartbeat of the civil rights movement now with black lives matter that's not overtly christian indeed often it's it's in overt terms anti-christian but it's still manifestly drawing on those traditions and i think that again that's why it's kind of you know transplanted so easily here. The interesting thing is that we've lost, what we have lost in Britain is the sense that did exist in the 18th century, that Britain was that country, that Britain was chosen by God, and that Britain was the city on the hill.
马丁·路德·金绝对奉为民权运动核心的东西。现在有了“黑人的命也是命”，这虽然不是公开的基督教运动，实际上通常以公开的反基督教词汇出现，但它显然仍在汲取这些传统的养分。我认为这再次解释了为什么它在这里能如此轻易地移植。有趣的是，我们在英国失去了一种在18世纪确实存在的感觉，即英国就是那个国家，英国是被上帝选中的国家，英国就是山巅之城。
No one believes that now. No, but I think that what you see in Britain, what you also see in America, which is a sense that we are kind of unique in our evil. Oh yeah, we definitely see that. That dignified by by by our wickedness by you know we we are the the enslaver we are that we are Babylon we are you know the evil empire and therefore we need to repent of that um and and only by repenting can we be brought into the light um and and I think that you know the the the sense that both America and Britain,
现在没有人相信这个了。不，但我认为你在英国所看到的，你在美国也能看到，那就是一种认为我们在邪恶方面是独一无二的意识。哦，是的，我们绝对能看到这一点。被我们的邪恶所赋予尊严，通过，你知道的——我们是奴役者，我们是巴比伦，我们是，你知道的，邪恶帝国，因此我们需要对此忏悔，并且只有通过忏悔我们才能被引入光明。而且我认为，你知道的，美国人和英国人都有的这种意识，
that both Americans have and the British have, that somehow there's a kind of deep stain of evil there that needs to be purged and repented for. It's a kind of arrogance almost. It's a kind of solipsism. It's a narcissism. It's a narcissism. It's placing us at the center of
即某种深重的邪恶污迹需要被涤荡和忏悔。这几乎是一种傲慢。这是一种唯我论。这是一种自恋。这是一种自恋。这把我们置于历史的中心，
history at the fulcrum of history even if you know 100 years ago it's because the british empire was great now it's because the british empire was uniquely evil um it it's a kind of narcissism i agree with you i mean that's something that britain and america definitely share there's no conflict in the world that there won't be somebody who says it was either the british empire's fault for misdrawing maps, or it's the CIA's fault plotting in the name of international Americanised capitalism. And it's always putting themselves at the centre of the story, and their own
置于历史的支点上，即使，你知道的，100年前这是因为大英帝国很伟大，现在是因为大英帝国格外的邪恶。这是一种自恋，我同意你的看法。我是说，这是英国和美国绝对共享的特质。世界上不会发生这样的冲突：总会有人跳出来说，要么是大英帝国画错地图惹的祸，要么是中央情报局以国际美国化资本主义的名义密谋策划的祸端。这总是把他们自己置于故事的中心，以及他们自己的
moral failings. I don't think you get the same thing in France, for instance, which would be the obvious parallel to us. The French don't think that, and of course, as we discussed in a previous episode, people like the Dutch are delighted by their own empire. To be fair to the Dutch, not all of them because the dutch also were part of this anglo-american atlantic world of protestantism so i think that that the dutch also are to that extent perhaps
道德缺陷的中心。我认为你在法国就不会遇到这种情况，法国对我们来说是一个明显的对照物。法国人并不那样认为，而且当然，正如我们在前一期节目中讨论的那样，像荷兰人这样的人为他们自己的帝国感到高兴。公平对待荷兰人，并非所有人如此，因为荷兰人也是这种盎格鲁-美国大西洋新教世界的一部分，所以我认为荷兰人在某种程度上也属于——
am i not right as well the big yugo survey shows the dutch are prouder of their own imperial past than anyone else i think they said that 40 of the dutch were but also that means 60 aren't and they're huge kind you know there's huge debates in uh in in the netherlands about than anyone else i think they said that 40 of the dutch were but also that means 60 aren't and they're huge kind of you know there's huge debates in uh in in the netherlands about was it black pete who is uh that's um a festive figure who turns up wearing blackface and i think that's a kind of you know very much yeah the kind of debate that that is informed by american cultural concerns um so anyway yeah interesting stuff do we have another question oh here's a great one here's a great one this is very much for you um tim carter was mtv and
我说的难道不对吗？大型民意调查显示，荷兰人比其他人更为其帝国的过去感到骄傲。我想他们说40%的荷兰人是这样的。但这也意味着60%的人不是，并且在——你知道的，荷兰国内存在着巨大的辩论，关于——比其他人更为其帝国的过去感到骄傲。我想他们说40%的荷兰人是这样的。但这也意味着60%的人不是，并且在——你知道的，荷兰国内存在着巨大的辩论，关于——是黑彼得吗？那是，呃，一个涂着黑脸登场的节日人物，我认为这是一种，你知道的，非常典型的、由美国文化关切所塑造的辩论。所以无论如何，是的，很有趣的事情。我们还有另一个问题吗？哦，这里有一个很棒的问题，这是一个很棒的问题，这非常适合你，蒂姆·卡特问：MTV和
friends more instrumental at exporting americanization than u.s foreign policy okay so i've actually never seen i've never seen an episode of friends and i never will i'll tell you that um why why why the hostility to friends i just look i just hate the the thought it's what you are it's the syrupy isn't it it's all sentimental kind of it's i don't know kind of no but it's very facts is it you like for you you're a big fan of friends i was i certainly watched friends when it was on yeah this is this is poor stuff okay so were they more instrumental in exporting Americanisation than US foreign policy?
《老友记》在出口美国化方面，是不是比美国的外交政策发挥了更大的作用？好吧，实际上我从来没有看过——我从来没有看过一集《老友记》，而且我永远也不会看，我得告诉你……为什么？为什么对《老友记》这么大敌意？我就是看——我就是讨厌那种想法，那种感觉太——那是你的一贯作风，那种甜腻腻的对吧？全都是那种感伤的情调，我不知道，某种——不，但它非常受欢迎，对吧？你喜欢《老友记》吗？你是《老友记》的超级粉丝吗？我——当它热播的时候我确实看过《老友记》，是的。这——这水平太低了。好吧，那么它们在出口美国化方面，是否比美国的外交政策发挥了更大的作用？
Yes, undoubtedly. Talking about them more broadly. So as far back as the 1920s, Will Hayes, who was the sort of head of the American motion picture industry, said, you know, the film, the cinema, is to us what the gunboat and the flag and the kind of the manufacturing were to Britain. So these are going to carry American values all across the world. And of course they have. And the American governments and indeed the CIA actually put a lot
是的，毫无疑问。广义上来说。早在20世纪20年代，威尔·海斯——他是美国电影业的某种负责人——就曾说过，你知道，电影，电影院，对我们而言，就相当于炮舰、国旗和制造业对英国的意义。所以这些东西将会把美国的价值观带到全世界。当然，它们也确实做到了。美国政府，实际上还有中央情报局，在冷战期间投入了大量资金去支持艺术，支持美国文化，因为他们非常清楚，软实力往往比硬实力重要得多。人们会对硬实力产生抵抗，但对软实力不会。而且我认为，是的，MTV——当然，关于MTV有趣的一点是，MTV一开始播放的是英国乐队的音乐，因为他们已经制作了音乐录影带，而美国乐队在这方面反应非常迟钝。但是美国——更广泛地说，摇滚乐，以及，我不太了解美国的电视，但毫无疑问是美国的电影——我认为电视，它们当时——当我长大的时候，美国电视被视为有点廉价和俗气。难道你不同意吗？它有点像那种，你知道的，ITV的《达拉斯》。《达拉斯》，对，《达拉斯》——我的意思是，那东西
of money in the Cold War into backing the arts and into backing American culture because they were well aware that soft power was often much more important than than hard power there'd be resistance to hard power but not soft and i think yeah mtv um funny thing about mtv of course is that mtv at first was british bands because they had got they've done videos and american bands were very slow to do it but america but rock and roll more broadly and i don't know about american television about but certainly american film i think tv they were you know american tv when i was growing up was seen as slightly cheap and nasty when you agree that it was kind of you know it's a bit itv dallas well dallas yeah dallas i mean it was that
基本上全都是关于美国资本主义罪恶的。因为那正是它在做的事情。那是美国对《唐顿庄园》的回应，对吧？它基本上是在兜售一种人们渴望吞下的关于自身的刻板印象。它基本上是在迎合牛仔帽和德克萨斯石油大亨的形象。
was so that was all about the kind of evils of American capitalism, basically. Because that's what that was doing. That's America's answer to Downton Abbey, isn't it? It's basically selling a stereotype of itself that people want to eat. It's basically pandering to the kind of cowboy hats and Texas oil men.
我的意思是，当我们制作乡间别墅剧时，我们做的也是我们自己品牌的最低公约数版本。是的，嗯，这也许是美国化一个有趣的例子，那就是——Netflix上的那个叫什么来着？《布里杰顿》。是的。我从来没看过那个。那是极其美国化的版本，不是吗？不，我很高兴谈论它，因为我也没看过，所以我其实不想谈论一个我没看过的事物。不过是的，那确实看起来非常美式……这从来没阻止你在第一个问题上发表高论。不，那样说太严厉了。
I mean, that's what we do when we make country house dramas. It's just the lowest common denominator version of your own brand yes um which is kind of an interesting example of americanization perhaps is uh what's it that one on um netflix bridgerton yeah i've never seen that that's very americanized version of a no i'm very happy to talk about it because i haven't seen it either so i don't really want to talk about something i haven't seen but yes that does seem to be a very American... Never stopped you in the first. No, that's very harsh.
不管怎样，让我们直接从那个极其不公平的无端指责中跳过去，来看史蒂芬·克拉克的提问。他是节目的好朋友，他问：青少年是美国化时期留下的最伟大遗产吗？所以，青少年，这绝对是美国化的产物。这是美国公关人员创造的概念，这个想法。它源于，我认为是30年代。部分原因是因为美国的年轻人比他们的欧洲同龄人更早拥有金钱和独立性，
Anyway, let's move straight on from that incredibly unfair aspersion to a question from Stephen Clark, good friend of the show, who asks, is the teenager the greatest legacy of the period of Americanisation? So teenagers, it's definitely Americanized. It's an American PR man's creation, the idea. It comes from, I think, the 30s. And it's partly because American kids had money and independence
基本上是因为如果经济状况良好，美国的经济就会更好。所以这一切都关乎市场，这一切都关乎向你开放的消费品。这是美国化时期最伟大的遗产吗？这是一个有趣的问题。我是说，青少年绝对是美国的产物。你知道，以前有过青春期少年（adolescents），但从来没有过青少年（teenagers）。
earlier than their European equivalents, basically because the American economy, if you were doing well, was doing better. So it's all about the market, and it's all about the consumer goods open to you. Is it the greatest legacy of the period of Americanisation? It's an interesting question. I mean, the teenager is definitely an American creation. You know, there have been adolescents, but there haven't been teenagers.
而且，是的，这是最伟大的遗产吗？我是说，它是最伟大的遗产之一，对吧？看到你真诚地在思考真是太棒了。这种情况太少见了。这是一个重大的历史问题，能看到你那伟大的大脑在运转……好吧，你知道的，我在这么多的替代选项中筛选。我觉得鉴于此，我们应该画上句号了，
And, yeah, is it the greatest legacy? I mean, it's one of the great ones, isn't it? It's so great to see you genuinely thinking. Happens so rarely. A huge historical question, and to see your mighty brain. Well, you know, I'm sifting through so many alternatives. And I think that on that note, we should come to an end
因为你可以离开并好好思考一下这个问题。我们可以为我们的下一期播客做准备，下一期我们将重返欧洲。我们将与作家兼历史学家卡佳·霍耶一起探讨普鲁士和德国的诞生。这是一个非常好的主题。我们已经录制完了。而且它实际上非常棒。多米尼克！我向听众们强烈推荐它。
because you can go away and have a ponder on that. And we can gear ourselves up for our next podcast, which will be coming back to Europe. We're looking at Prussia and the birth of Germany with the writer and historian Katja Hoyer. That's a very good one. We've done it already. And it's actually a very good one. Dominic! I recommend it to the listeners.
多米尼克，你彻底破坏了这种幻觉。现在我们进入了一种“回到未来”的模式。我想人们会喜欢这样的。我想他们喜欢那种不确定感：这期节目到底是录了还是没录？是的，我们已经录过了，伙计们。多米尼克完全
Dominic, you've totally spoiled the illusion. Now we're in a kind of back to the future. I think people will like that. I think they like the sense of uncertainty. Have they recorded it or haven't they? Yeah, we've already recorded it, guys. Dominic's totally
鱼雷般击碎了那种试图营造连贯感、紧迫感和危机感的尝试。你有点像是在那里引入了欧洲后现代主义，
torpedoed that attempt to try and create a sense of coherence. A sense of urgency and jeopardy. You kind of introduced European post-modernism
然后把它彻底给毁了。不管怎样，就说到这里，拜拜。拜拜。拜拜。
there and totally ruined it. Anyway, on that note, bye-bye. Bye-bye. Bye-bye. community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
社区，请访问 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录文本中的任意句子即可发表评论。